welcome to this video against the black
operator okay US flag that is rated 2222
okay let's see how strong the French
defence hmm okay I'll play this funky
move 496 sort of a pipeline of some team
mates of mine so I am have some vague
idea Oh displayed it's a bit of a don't
try this at home variation which awesome
well it's playable but you really need
to know what you're doing because the
knight on c6 is some of course blocking
the typical c5 counterplay typical
typical for French well that's
interesting the white player plays one
of the critical lines or less this is
not really critical because it gives
away deform the question is some can I
take it without being without being
attacked and probably not but I think I
must take it right what else is there
okay Bishop deform this of course what
I'm talking about he can play long
castles hmm rook team won but I can take
I can go to f6 yeah yeah this is
certainly some compensation but it's
it's hard to play without that
basically forced to grab this pawn more
that's surprising why would why would
you help me developing okay yeah so
probably here okay can go Bishop d3 95
but I'm not sure how how danger it is
how dangerous it really is they go h6
you probably will play 95 anyway it some
sort of a given that this was going to
happen yeah i'm a bit behind in
development of course or maybe here yeah
that's actually a good more 95 Bishop f5
exchanging this should be helpful
yeah of course why it is so needs to try
to muddy the water the waters I think is
the right right way to say it right okay
so what I'm taking taking here now let's
meet on edge sadness a bit bit tricky
don't want to play g6 really it's not
that bad can also give the check iam
hmm i don't know g6 so i have this check
here probably that's okay and rock the
aid check now that should be this should
be quite good now how does he protect
you for I only see a weird-looking moves
like them like a queen II to Queen
Quincy warm yeah maybe it looks a bit a
bit odd but
yeah maybe maybe you can do that
hmm
okay but to have one minute forty i
played a couple of 15-minute games
before that always a bit tricky the some
change of time control I tend to play
even slower than usual okay but the Sun
looks ok now i believe Knight f3 may be
threatening Queen takes a form it's a
neat little trick rock d bundela can
play rock you one I should have got gone
to e6 may be attending group d 8 hmm
this was better I guess they are ugly
one yeah I don't really get to to the
default now that's a bit of a problem
we are not much choice here he gets the
H file but it's not clear that it is
helping him so much Knight takes Queen
takes Queen age 3 i've got queen h5
don't think think this should defend
really ok well this is just a good end
game f6 or what you have six King g7 and
then activate on the fighting look h8
now even ok so if I'm going on to attack
the queenside check ok want to let I
don't want to allow him to go to the
same rank
so I've got the King cut off and this is
good and the rook is protecting the
Queen side so I can now use the King to
advance my two hands one majority rook
h2 is the idea gather should this should
be a wind really don't okay maybe King
it to check take stakes kicking our
three wins they've pond should be a
winning King and porn endgame if you
move the rope to g7 i take c 3 now
anyway
couldn't take because at the end he
promotes the airport funny line check my
result how to promote switched off
because recently and I needed to to do
something with under promotion need to
switch that bagon really um okay well
this was a tricky game I probably allow
it a bit too much sham I think I was a
bit too here I was a bit too fascinated
by this trick ok well the computer says
I'm flattered wedding yeah maybe I mean
maybe I am but I like that better this
looks like I'm just controlling things
he can play this check but it's not
really not really doing in many any good
and I have the default maybe this was
easier ok mother computer here even
wants to take on edge for which I don't
get ok Quincy one made ok this the seems
it seems okay yeah yeah yeah I'm just
winning according to the machine so
there is no no tricks that are that I
overlooked he certainly had a
compensation at first i'm pretty sure
but it was a bit surprising some of the
moves I thought that okay maybe maybe
it's just surprising because i'm
calculating it wrong I mean I thought
about something like that but you can't
just take him check so maybe it was ok
what he did but I only now try to
improve but Bishop f5 is citizen this is
very important defensive resource
yeah yeah well the computer is giving
black a very big edge throughout so
maybe I was a very dumb I mean it was
not justified that I was worried so much
I don't know alright thanks for watching